ja der absolute schock an deutschen
zapfsäulen preise weit über 2 euro
deutschland wartet auf mit diesem sprit
preisschock an den tanken dabei wurden
uns zum mittwoch dem ersten juni doch
der tank rabatt versprochen millionen
deutsche autofahrer sollen dann endlich
beim tanken deutlich entlastet werden
wegen der steigenden preise hat die
ampel koalition ja die spritsteuer
gesenkt doch ist das wirklich ein segen
für alle autofahrer oder geht dieser
schuss vielleicht nach hinten los denn
die koalition hat die rechnung offenbar
ohne die ölkonzerne gemacht die
verdienen an der krise nämlich kräftig
mit
es sollte das große geschenk an
millionen deutscher autofahrer werden
doch jetzt droht das chaos an den
zapfsäulen ab erster juni sollen
autofahrer weniger für sprit bezahlen
benzin soll 35 cent günstiger werden
diese um 17 cent von juni bis august
sollen autofahrer an der tankstelle also
weniger zahlen und spürbar entlastet
werden sollen vor sechs wochen klang die
ankündigung des finanzministers so wir
werden den
spritpreis reduzieren bei einem benzin
um 30 cent pro liter und waren diesel um
14 cent pro liter wir gehen damit auf
das minimum der europäischen energie
besteuerung zurück über diese
ankündigung freuten sich die autofahrer
aber wird aus dem tank rabatt ein
spritpreis schock geht der schuss also
nach hinten los
experten fürchten
der tank rabatt könnte zu spritmangel
und chaos an den zapfsäulen führen der
grund die große nachfrage
und sogar der wirtschaftsminister ist
skeptisch na klar ist auch eine
situation denkbar dass jetzt alle in der
letzten woche im mai nicht mehr handeln
und dafür alle am ersten juni zur
tankstelle fahren und dann ist die
nachfrage noch viel größer und das
beziehen wird auf einmal noch ein
kostbares guten haben wir den preis
gesenkt und in wahrheit geht er nach
oben die sorge die steuerentlastung
kommt gar nicht bei den autofahrern an
denn die ölkonzerne sind nicht
verpflichtet die entlastung
weiterzugeben die ölmultis verdienen
sich ohnehin an der krise eine goldene
nase
statt zu sinken könnten die spritpreise
ab mittwoch sogar steigen dann hätte die
politik den autofahrern kein geschenk
gemacht sondern ein dickes ei